can we talk about hands yeah so I buy a
cookies I train karate oh my god
so I buy cookie please tell him I buy a
cookie and I go this is not vegan cuz
the guy sold me and he said this is a
vegan cookie I go this is not vegan it's
too good to be abused gotta be butter
and Adam Bryan goes let me try sticks
his hand like first of all who grabs a
anything like this like it's a turtle
yeah my plucky only has three fingers
stuck to pinky yeah dr. pinky grass yeah
la crabbed it broke a piece off touch
the entire cookie the entire cookie and
then shoved all four fingers in his
mouth to the second knuckle who's this
guy and then pulled it out it was just I
had to clean all the chocolate on my
finger dude well I what I do is I drag
and then wiped it off like that and I go
I don't want to share any finger food
items with you but because I drag my
fingers along the cookie I started from
the very edge of the crust drag along
then just I know just to put my mark on
my arms and then I broke it off I've not
seen that yet
like I know the joke is that you're
everyone thinks you're old that's what
that's like a comment but a lot of
people I know you're being a dick right
now but the way you ate that cookie is
old old that's like how uh that's fair
like someone that's in a nursing home
you're being shot not vegan and [ __ ]
sucks his fingers up knuckles Dee yeah I
did I did put I did get aggressive with
my finger you know I wanted a piece you
did yeah I don't love it I don't want it
now it's I stopped eating it me - no in
the camera all this not even if you come
jumping look I stopped beating it it was
look oh there's the spheres look one one
here yeah one right here and then we're
there then you broke it off like that
but no he fasted really see am I making
it up let me see investigations into
taxes
you did it you're
your honor you know you know they'll
stare meadows ten minutes tell me that
show how you did it sure I did I just
show my you did I'm gonna go along here
I'll reenact it Brendan this is there's
no way this is vegan I'm gonna try yeah
maybe you'll try it let Brian try peace
get your old buddy part that's exactly
how he did it right but he was talking
to me as if no one knows he cramped all
his finger to his [ __ ] mouth I was
like he's talking about you know you
know I really like what Bubble Boy I'm
like oh did you just cram all your
[ __ ] fingers in your mouth no [ __ ]
given either was there Brian sorry it's
just still tryin solve it was the last
one my fingers have my whistle are very
clear move everything clean not what's
yours go [ __ ] yourself it's yours but
also when the show's done I'll try it
joke Oh Congrats on all your success
thank you so much right now yeah yeah
yeah yeah watch your tongue oh good
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]